Speaker 1: Welcome to the David Pakman show.
I am Ferron cousins from Ring of Fire here
with you once again.
We've got a phenomenal show coming up today.
Obviously, we've got to talk about Trump's
lawsuit against the DOJ and the revelation
that there were 700 pages of classified documents
retrieved so far this year from Mar a Lago.
We've got two of the individuals who were
plotting to kidnap Governor Gretchen Whitmer
from michigan.
They have been convicted.
We've got don jr excusing his father's actions.
We've got alex jones walking back his endorsement
of ron desantis.
All kinds of things coming up on today's show.
So let's jump right in.
Obviously, one of the bigger things that happened
early this week is the fact that Donald Trump
not only filed a lawsuit against the DOJ seeking
a special master to go through the documents,
make sure there's nothing privileged in there.
But also in the filing, it appears that his
lawyers actually admitted that he did the
things that, of course, he is being accused
of right here twice in the document, meaning
the, you know, lawsuit and the other documents
that have come to light.
Trump admits he took government documents,
which is illegal under the Espionage Act and
the Presidential Records Act.
Huh?
You know.
Speaker 2: I'm not a lawyer.
Speaker 1: I work with lawyers.
I am the editor of a legal magazine.
But I got to tell you, usually when lawyers
file motions, they don't admit to the crimes
that their clients have been accused of.
And yet.
Right.
They're clear as day.
There's two separate times where his lawyers
admit, yes, we had the documents.
The FBI at one point told us to secure them
a little bit better.
So Donald Trump said, put a second lock on
the door.
That that's in the document.
And then, of course, they admitted it again
when they said, if the FBI, you know, all
they had to do was come ask, we would have,
you know, given them the things that they
were after.
So you're admitting you did it.
And we know from last week, of course, that
reports came out saying Donald Trump is unable
to attract decent lawyers, one, because they
don't want to tie their name to it because
they know how unpredictable Trump is.
And if he does something stupid, the lawyer
gets blamed for it.
They don't want to be a part of that.
And also, they're afraid they're never going
to get paid if they do legal work for him.
So Donald Trump, of course, is left with what
I like to call the bottom of the barrel.
Now, you know what?
That's not even fair to barrels.
These are not lawyers from the bottom of the
barrel.
He had to tip the barrel over and dig down
a couple of feet to find legal minds.
Horrible enough to admit in their own filings
that, yeah, I mean, he did it.
But is it always bad if he does?
It is is it always a crime?
But all that aside, the lawsuit itself, depending
on who you ask, is either going to succeed
or fail.
And I know that's a very weird thing to say,
but again, it depends on which legal expert
you're talking to.
You're reading or you're seeing.
You know, there are massive threads on Twitter
explaining this because everybody seems to
have a different thought on what is happening
here.
A lot of them say that this lawsuit well,
pretty much all of them say the lawsuit is
just an effort to stall.
Right.
That's a given.
Speaker 2: We understand that he's stalling.
Speaker 1: The real question becomes whether
or not the lawsuit itself can be successful.
That's where the divide happens because some
legal experts and I'm talking about all the
people, these are all people on the left.
Some say it's an absolute farce and it has
no chance of being successful because the
special master would be appointed if they
believed some of the retrieved materials.
700 pages of classified documents were privileged.
And that is where another dichotomy breaks
down.
So if it's attorney client privilege, then
a special master would in this particular
instance, be warranted under most circumstances?
Not necessarily.
All right.
If they're documents that Trump and his lawyer
are discussing, committing crimes together
outside of what he's being represented for,
then, no, that would not fall under attorney
client privilege.
If it is Donald Trump communicating with his
lawyer about legal actions, things like that.
That is privileged.
You can't have those.
The other kind of privilege is executive privilege,
which, of course, we have heard Donald Trump
say some of these things are executive privilege.
And that's not going to fly.
You're not going to get a special master because
you say.
Speaker 2: These things are covered under
executive privilege.
Speaker 1: There's one person on the planet
who has the authority to determine whether
or not something is covered under executive
privilege.
That person right now is President Joe Biden.
So if Biden were to come out and say none
of these are executive privilege, then guess
what?
None of them are executive privilege.
If he doesn't do that and Trump did claim
privilege over some of them, they would still
have that executive privilege distinction
until the next person in line, whoever that
president will be, if it's Biden now or anybody
else down the road, takes it away.
That's how the executive privilege works.
Once it's there, it is there, and it can transfer
from administration to administration.
But once you leave office, it's out of your
control.
So if the next person in line says, no, it's
not covered, then it's not covered.
And then, of course, you would not get a special
master.
Having said all of that, let me say this,
because, again, depending on what kind of
privilege it may or may not take effect, depending
on what's in the privileged, it may or may
not take effect any of that.
I don't care.
I'm in favor of the Special Master.
And there's one very specific and I feel it's
a good reason for everybody to say, you know
what, we'll do the special master thing.
Give Trump what he wants right now.
Because he's making a big deal of this.
So if he gets that special master.
All of his followers are going to look at
it and say, okay, good, we have oversight.
And then if you find the crimes, you know,
if well, the having the documents themselves
was the crime.
If you find it is what you think it is and
you can indict him.
Having that special master there, it's not
going to convince Trump Hill then attack the
special master.
It's not going to convince the MAGA hat wearing
crowd that everything was legitimate.
But what it will do is it will convince all
of those Republicans who are right now on
the fence.
They don't know whether or not to support
what's happening or to be against it.
Those are the people that are going to say,
well, there was a special master.
They had the oversight.
Trump they gave Trump what he wanted.
And it still came to that conclusion.
So I guess this was real.
I guess this was legitimate.
I'm not even saying, folks, that you're going
to have a large number of people who do that.
But even if you have a handful of them, that's
more than you've got right now.
So why not just do it yet?
Is it going to slow things down a little bit?
Sure.
But if you go ahead and agree and give in
to the demands of this lawsuit, which I am
typically against giving in to any demands
of these right wingers.
But if you do it now, you're going to avoid
a lengthy court process where nothing's going
to be able to happen in the interim.
So agree to it today.
Get the special master, then start going through
the documents.
You save yourself a lot of time.
That way, Trump doesn't get to stall it, but
for more than one a week.
And he gets what he wants.
And some folks out there might view this a
little bit more legitimately.
Speaker 2: Than they already were.
Speaker 1: That's why I think the special
master is a good idea.
I do think it's something that the DOJ needs
to entertain.
It's not obviously out of the realm of possibility.
It happens all the time in criminal investigations.
Just do it.
Give this thing even more legitimacy, is what
I say.
Take away one of Donald Trump's biggest talking
points.
He'll still use it, but it's not going to
be as effective against this many people if
he just do do what he wants right now.
Speaker 2: And reap
the benefits later.